- Okay.
Hi, good afternoon, everybody.
Thank you so much for
joining us for this talk.
My name is Florian Carle,
I'm the manager of the
Yale Quantum Institute,
and the host of this
series of nontechnical talk
on science and the humanities
that are cosponsored
by the Franke Program in
Science and the Humanities.
This series is trying
to combat science phobia
and quantum physics phobia too
by introducing other medium
to the field and talking
about two different topics
that has the intersection of...
So in the past,
you can see some of the slides
behind me or on your screens.
In the past, we had talks about
quantum physics and music.
We had physics and dance, we
had mathematics and crochet.
And today we are very excited
to be joined by Stewart Smith
to talk about "The Hapless Dreamers".
And so in a very exciting
talk about digital art,
augmented reality, and quantum simulators.
So we started this series in 2017,
and this is our 14th event of the series.
So to give you a bit of
introduction to Stewart Smith.
So he's a digital artist
and an AR technologist.
He has worked at a very
well renowned hybrid studio
like the Google Creative
Lab and the Data Arts team.
And funded more technology
and strategy consequently.
And is also currently the head of consumer
augmented reality at
Unity, the gaming giant.
And so he received his
MFA from Yale University
in graphic design, and his
artwork has been exhibited
in the Museum of Modern Art in New York,
at the ZKM in Germany, at
the SF MOMA in San Francisco,
and is part of the permanent collection
at the Fondation Cartier in Paris.
If all of that was not
enough, on the side,
he taught himself how to code,
and he created and maintained
the browser based quantum simulator, QJS.
So he'll talk a bit more about that.
So I think that's something
that's gonna be very exciting
for the quantum crowd.
So the talk will last about 50 minutes,
and then you will have time for questions.
For the people on Zoom over there,
There's a feature at the bottom
of your screen called Q&A,
so feel free to type your question in,
and then we'll take them as they pop in.
Please help me welcome Stewart Smith,
and thank you for being here.
- Thank you so much.
(audience clapping)
Hi.
As Florian said, I'm Stewart Smith.
My background is in art,
code, and graphic design.
But I think it's also important
to try to find the fun in making things.
I do have a hard time
describing what I mean by that.
And so what I wanna do is step through
some more visual examples,
and maybe those examples
will promote some discussion,
some arguments, some debate,
and hopefully just describe
what it is that I do.
I'll give you a little
overview of a few things,
and then I'll go deep
on about four projects.
So here's a little overview.
I've made music videos
using vintage computers,
which is a strange thing to
do, but I'd say quite fun.
Games that are played with Windows
instead of within Windows.
So a version of pong for the browser
that actually uses popup windows to play.
Very large panoramic data animations
that take up entire rooms,
so you can walk into this animated data
that's all around you.
I've even crafted software synthesizers.
This runs right in any web
browser. It's open source.
You can even plug in a MIDI keyboard
right into your computer,
and you can play with it.
And with any luck, let's
just see if this...
(synthesizer playing)
So there you go, you can try
this out on your own time
and I'll turn the volume down
so we don't get a feedback loop there.
I also got involved with
consumer virtual reality
when it was just beginning to take off.
So around that time, I
wrote the VR controller
for a 3D library called Three JS.
It provided an easy generic
way for web-based VR apps
to support a bunch of
different hand controllers,
'cause you don't wanna
worry about supporting
a Gear VR controller and Daydream.
You wanna worry about your game, right?
Or whatever experience you're making.
So this made it a lot easier
to focus on the fun parts,
and I took care of the hard bits for you.
Over at the Google Data Arts team,
we used my VR controller library
to power this VR music video
for the band LCD Soundsystem.
And I'm gonna talk a little
more about that in a bit.
You could dance along to the song in VR,
and a recording of your
dance would then become
part of the video itself.
So each one of these cone people
with the little baton hands
is someone who danced to the song
and had their dance recorded,
and then incorporated into this video.
And yeah, you can see some people
are very enthusiastic about this.
(audience laughing)
So I also released "Space Rocks",
which was just a personal project,
and not affiliated with Google,
or really awesome bands or anything.
This was my personal tribute
to Atari's 1979 classic,
"Asteroids", but in VR, of course.
And I took my VR controller
library and I added something
I called multichannel haptic feedback,
which made it super easy to
add complex haptic commands
to your VR apps.
So if you need to feel
kickback in the controller
from firing your laser,
but there's also like
the hum of the engine revving up and down.
That's really complicated.
This multichannel haptic
feedback thing made it very easy
to just describe and code
succinctly what you want,
and it takes care of the rest.
So that was a lot of fun, of course.
A few years later,
Oculus upped the game by
adding hand tracking support
for web based virtual reality.
And I immediately wrote
this Handy JS library.
You'll notice JS is a big theme.
I love browser based stuff and JavaScript,
so you'll see that pop up a lot.
So what this does is it makes recording
and then recognizing hand poses on the fly
really quick and easy to do.
So instead of just pinch
gestures to select things,
you can recognize tons of shapes,
including the whole ASL
finger spelling alphabet.
Finger guns is the most fun.
You ever as a child,
just pretend you could shoot
lasers out of your fingers?
That may sound childish,
but come on, it's fun.
I made it possible, so there you go.
- [Audience Member] You
mean you made it possible
for us to imagine that.
You only made it possible to-
- That was a bit of a stretch,
yeah, that was a bit of...
I didn't think anyone would call me on it,
but I'm glad you're keeping me honest.
- [Audience Member] But
I work on lasers, if you-
(Stewart laughing)
If you could do it with your fingers,
I'd really like to know how.
(Stewart laughing)
So would I. That would be fun.
So I've made a lot of
work outside VR, too.
I started coding when I was quite young,
but I'm educated as a
graphic designer and artist.
I didn't study computer science.
I've worked, well, I
guess you covered this.
I've been a commissioned artist,
lucky enough to have some work
in different galleries and museums.
I'm also a lifelong mediocre
to terrible musician,
so you'll see music pop
up a lot in stuff I do.
And I even enjoy writing
essays occasionally,
despite having no lessons to do that.
I think my friends who are
actually gifted in that medium
cringe when they read what I've written,
but still, it's fun to write.
It's fun to communicate with people.
Speaking of which, and
cringeworthy things.
I started to become
aware of design as a kid.
I had started this low budget
magazine as a teenager,
or a zine, as the kids say.
Basically, as a ruse, as
a hack, this was a way
that I could meet and interview
some of my favorite bands,
and their record labels would
send me the music for free.
Pre-digital streaming.
But that was pretty amazing.
I don't know if you've
ever tried to meet a band
after a show, they purposely
make it impossible.
But if you get in touch with
the publicist and say, well,
I don't even really want to meet the band.
I just have this assignment,
I have to interview them.
They're like, oh, well right this way.
And you get to meet everyone.
And they will send you all of the ephemera
and music and albums and
things, and it's great.
So I'd do that, and then
I'd also interview musicians
about the heavy political
topics of the day.
So that was a way to combine an interest
in music and politics.
And all of this meant that I,
this graphic design is terrible.
This is teenage graphic design.
But what it exposed me to is
I had to start thinking about
visual hierarchy and typography,
the interplay of text and image.
So even though this was
terrible, it planted good seeds.
Seeds that I would later follow
all the way here to Yale.
So I received my MFA in graphic design,
just a few blocks over.
Somehow, somehow I squeaked through.
And after Yale, I moved
to Europe for a while.
I became an artist in residence at ZKM,
or Zakheim, as they'd say.
That's the Center for
Art and Media Technology
in Karlsruhe, Germany,
in Southern Germany.
Beautiful, beautiful place.
Folks there might say
that it's very boring.
I thought it was quiet and lovely,
and a really good place to get work done.
But eventually I moved back to the US,
and joined Google's
Creative Lab in New York,
which is sort of a subversive
marketing department,
now that I think about it.
And later I jumped to
Google's Data Arts team
to do some more music video work.
I've also spent some time at various
other large tech companies doing
whatever large tech companies do.
And I'm currently head of
consumer augmented reality
at Unity, and everyone knows Unity, right?
Have you heard? Yeah.
So our game engine is all about making
real time 3D rendering for the masses.
70% of the world's games
are made with Unity.
And we're not just 70%
of, sorry, 70% of mobile.
Definitely make sure I get that right.
We're not just 70% of mobile
games, we're 50% of all games.
So if you play games,
you've played something made with Unity.
So like I said, that's...
- [Audience Member] Meaning
you're the drive software.
So I'm the person who has
no idea what Unity is.
- Unity is a way to make
game development much easier.
And distribution.
So you could make your game
once in the Unity editor.
And then you can say, I
wanna launch it for Windows,
I wanna launch it for Mac,
I wanna put it on VR headsets and whatnot.
And while there's still pain points
in the development of
complicated software,
Unity helps grease those wheels,
and make it much easier to do.
- [Audience Member] Does it have its own
programming language or
just use existing ones?
- Unity is primarily C# focused.
So if you're familiar
with C# or Java, C, C++,
any of those things will
translate nicely into Unity stuff.
Happy to talk more about
Unity too, after all this,
if you wanna talk about that.
But I wanna show you
four things that I think
are kind of different from each other,
and it'll give you a sense of
how I think about this stuff.
So the first one is a
project called "Racer".
This came out of Google Creative Lab.
Google's Chrome team was enjoying
this big market share for desktop.
So Google was very happy.
However, Chrome on mobile
was not so popular.
I think just people
weren't really aware of it.
And so the Google Chrome team asked us
to make an ad campaign.
Typical marketing ask.
Like let's do maybe some TV
spots, posters in the subway,
stuff like that.
And we said, no. (laughs)
We said, we have a better idea.
We were starting to
obsess over racing games,
and slot car racing games in particular.
And I started brainstorming
just random ideas about tracks
made of software that
could change on the fly,
that were modular.
And I also created some quirky crash demos
that were inspired by early vector games
like "Asteroids" and
"Tempest" and whatnot.
And we also had this idea
about racing across screens.
So you literally needed to have
multiple phones or tablets,
or what have, you next to each other.
It was taking this idea of social gaming,
and pushing you physically together.
This was obviously pre pandemic.
It'd be a little strange
to push that today.
And so this was the final result.
We said, no posters in the subway.
No TV spots.
Let's make this game that
shows off how powerful
Chrome for mobile really is.
So you don't just say, we can show you.
And we can make it fun.
So you actually want to be shown.
Our racing game needed a soundtrack.
And we actually convinced
this guy Giorgio Moroder
to score the soundtrack.
And he wrote individual
tracks for each phone.
So one phone would be
playing the percussion,
one would have like the
lead melody and so on.
And if you're not familiar with Giorgio,
he's an electronic disco legend.
And he's collaborated with
Daft Punk more recently.
He's a legend in the
community, I can't believe,
I still can't believe
we got him to do this.
So those were all the
ingredients for this game,
and here's what that
experience looked like.
(cars revving)
(thumping electronic music)
(text whooshing)
(phone tapping)
(phone beeping)
(phones beeping)
(cars revving)
So I think you can see how
you need to hug the track.
I should have maybe explained beforehand,
if you're not familiar with slot cars,
the whole idea is that
you don't get to steer.
You just have one big dumb gas pedal.
And you need to go as
fast as you possibly can
on the straightaways,
and then let up when you hit the curves,
otherwise you spin off the track.
And so we replicated that behavior here,
where your beautiful
flagship multi-touch device
was just used as one
big dumb button, which,
we thought there was some humor in that.
(Stewart laughing)
So, Sundar Pichai, who
is now Google's CEO,
He unveiled Racer at Google IO that year,
and the tech press loved it.
And so that's kind of
what we were aiming for,
was this recognition
in the tech community,
and then also in the broader community,
people just playing the game for fun.
But we also struck a chord
with the music press as well,
which we didn't really
expect, and that was awesome.
People were really getting onto the fact
that Giorgio Moroder had,
aside from Daft Punk,
he had come out of
retirement for us to do this.
Off the record, we made a
limited vinyl run pressing
of the soundtrack, and Giorgio
even signed our copies.
That was pretty great.
This was a fun project on
its own, but as a nice bonus,
we were awarded the Cannes
Lion Gold for creativity
and innovation on mobile devices.
You probably don't know what that is,
'cause it's a silly industry
award for like marketing.
But it just means people
thought it was cool.
(Stewart laughing)
That made us happy too.
So sadly, Racer is no longer live,
I think some of the website still exists,
but it'll say something like,
your network is too slow.
Which is just a fake error code for,
we were only gonna support this
for about 12 months anyway,
as a marketing campaign.
And now it's off the radar.
Otherwise I'd race you all,
we could have a competition up here.
(indistinct)
All right.
Next project, Autocompose.
This is a much less visual project,
and I think it demonstrates a predilection
for combining interests in
product design, marketing,
and also cutting edge research,
just kind of blending all
of these interests together.
So back in 2013 I had more
or less accidentally followed
ex-Google star Marissa Mayer to Yahoo.
And the narrative there was
that Marissa would rescue this
once great company that at
this point was falling apart.
And Yahoo Mail in particular
was in need of rescuing.
So we got this official ask
from the Yahoo Mail team,
from the product team.
They wanted a Valentine's
themed marketing campaign.
And I guess that just came to mind,
'cause it was late
January and they're like,
what's a reason to promote something?
Regardless of the reasoning,
they gave us this ask
near the end of January,
which meant we had about
three weeks until Valentine's Day hit.
And also because we needed to
put all these plans in motion
and into production
ahead of Valentine's Day,
we really had about two weeks.
So, it's kind of a nightmare scenario when
someone comes to you and
says, two weeks from now,
we need to have something
that changes the narrative
around Yahoo Mail from
everyone being upset
to people saying, oh,
isn't that a nice product?
(Stewart laughing)
So I had an idea for this.
It's an idea that I'd played
with a few years prior
during the height of the iSomething craze.
So think iMac, iTunes, iLife,
and the crown jewel of the time, the iPod.
iPhone and iPad were still
super secret skunkworks projects
that no one knew about.
And that idea was, iQuit.
I apologize for the language.
This was a resignation letter generator.
So your job, your
relationship, your friends,
get out of anything instantly with iQuit.
This is a real...
(audience member laughing)
Useful, right?
This is a real functioning
website that I launched.
You put in the email address
of who you want to quit,
and it would do the rest.
It would generate a random
formal letter of resignation,
and send it to them.
Yes, very useful.
The faux testimonials I had
on the website were absurd.
"I used to do corporate
advertising until I realized
having a soul is nice.
I fired up iQuit and bam,
now I can starve with pride."
(audience laughing)
It's just kind of ridiculous
faux testimonials.
Here's an actual sample email
that it generated
automatically on the fly.
"This email serves as my
formal letter of resignation,
effective immediately.
It's not my intention to injure
feelings with this letter,
but to merely illuminate a path
toward a more functional
environment for myself."
And it goes, it's ridiculous, right?
- [Audience Member]
Did you write all this?
- The way that I made
this original version is,
I had a list of opening lines,
tons of middling lines, and
then a few choice closers,
and it would randomly
assemble those on the fly.
- [Audience Member] So they
are kind of randomly assorted.
- And I'm glad you asked about that,
because that's the seeds of
what we're about to talk about.
So that's when it hit me,
this Valentine's Day campaign.
Writing love letters is hard.
"Dear Jane, you are so neat."
(audience laughing)
It's a pain, right?
So I quickly, taking that sort of humor,
I coded this demo that
constructed love letters
automatically right in the
Yahoo Mail compose window.
And if you didn't like the result,
you could just edit it yourself,
or click the auto compose button again
for a new composition.
So you can see it just
cycling through, you click,
and then it gives you these things.
I also created this interface
for our copywriters,
so they could craft their
lines and test them.
This is really,
this is like a showcase for
a good copywriter, right?
Because it's all about the
language that goes in there.
It's really all about the text.
And I feel like you rarely get to do that
in a tech marketing medium.
But here it is.
So I wrote the
pseudo-programming language.
So literally they can just write opener,
have a whole list of openers.
And then other, there's like
"Mad Libs" style replacements
and things that it could do as well.
And it would automatically
take what you've done in here
and use it as the contents
for what was being generated.
And this way they could test
if their lines really worked together.
Sometimes a brilliant line of text
seems like it could flow into another,
and then you see them juxtaposed,
and the language doesn't feel right.
So this was a way that
they could gut check
a bunch of compositions.
And also it was really important to me
that the number of permutations possible
exceeded the number of daily active users.
So that in theory, every
single person using Yahoo Mail
could generate a love letter,
and every one of them would be unique.
So it was a lot.
And we launched it in
time for Valentine's Day,
and it was a success.
We were able to change the
conversation around Yahoo Mail,
from hate at the time, to
something a bit more amused.
People were at least
smiling and sharing this.
Yeah, the sentiment was
positive for a while.
So because auto compose was a hit,
we immediately started looking for ways
to take it even further.
And you had asked about
how it was constructed,
and it was just lines of text,
and they were randomly assembled together.
That was good for a two week project,
but to really go further, we
needed actual machine learning.
And thankfully, right around that time,
Yahoo had purchased this
startup called Summly.
And what it did was
automatically summarize
long news articles into
very short snippets.
So I was able to take these ideas together
and sketch that out into a
patent for using existing emails
as training data for
constructing new email drafts.
So you have an email corpus
of all of your missives
to friends, your mom, or whatever,
and the way that you interact
with different people
will be different.
If you're emailing a professor,
I would imagine you don't
speak in the same way
that you might speak with
some of your friends.
There may be a bit of more
formality or what have you.
Or maybe not. I don't know.
I don't know your professors individually.
(laughs)
But the point was that we
could use machine learning
to look at those
correspondences and then predict
or imagine what another
correspondence would be
between you and that recipient.
So let's say you have the flu,
and you need to find a way
to apologize to your buddies
for missing an important birthday.
If you're really feeling sick,
do you wanna write that email,
or just let the computer write
it for you and apologize?
I'm skeptical about whether
we want any of this stuff.
But it was fun to work on.
- [Audience Member] Well you're certainly
making everybody lazier.
(Stewart and audience laughing)
A few years later, Google
did the same thing.
And instead of auto compose,
they called it Smart Reply.
So I'm not saying I invented Smart Reply,
but maybe it was just
in the air at the time.
I like to float that and pretend
I'm more important than I am.
Anyway, I wrote about all of this
in an essay called "The Charm Offensive".
So if you're curious to know more,
a semi humorous essay
about how this came to be.
Okay, sorry, second to last
one here, called Dance Tonite.
So virtual reality has
become a big part of my life
for the past few years.
And the first VR system that I ever tried
was a Vive dev kit.
And once I tried it, I knew immediately
I wanted to make stuff for VR.
But I'm a web guy, so I
had to find other people
who were building web-based VR tools.
And this was in the very
early days of this stuff,
and I started making
little demos like this,
where you'd be in this
weird rippling environment
of this kind of dream sand substance
that would swirl together to make objects.
I don't know, I thought it
was very artistic at the time.
And now I'm like, well, it's
a decent tech demo, I guess.
But these were the early days.
I also built some early co-presence demos.
And again, all this stuff
was running in the browser.
One day I got about 80
folks in Google Creative Lab
to join me in this little VR universe.
So everyone was these sort of peg people,
and they could look around and everyone
would have this randomly generated name
that was a random color
and a random animal.
And you could run around
like little Mario characters
and teleport between worlds,
but that was about it.
That was about the extent
of the interaction.
But for late 2015, not bad.
That was a technical feat.
I created this day and
night web app for my kids.
Their grandparents live in Europe,
and I wanted to give them
a better understanding
of how time zones work.
So here, they can float in space.
You put the headset on
and you're in outer space
above this rotating Earth.
And the city lights
come on as night falls,
and you can get a sense of how
it is the middle of the day
in one spot in the middle
of the night in another,
in a very visual, visceral sense.
So this universe is movable and scalable.
I was making something for my kids,
who are obviously a
little shorter than I am.
So the whole idea was that
you could grab the world
as if you were going to do pinch and zoom,
like on your phone.
And you could expand the
universe or contract it,
and rotate it, and put it
wherever was comfortable.
So you'd have the earth
kind of about this size,
just floating here.
And that's fun.
Or you could make it huge, and
you could be kind of floating
right next to the curvature of the Earth
and watching as it shifts
between day and night.
This was another thing
that I was working on
that does not seem to flow so smoothly
when we're trying to mirror screens here.
But this was a giant data
visualization of flight patterns.
And I recorded this to VR, and
you could do the same thing.
You could expand it and
you could actually sit
inside the Earth and look
out and see, well, here,
if we're not over the ocean,
there's a bit more to look at.
You could actually see all of this stuff
swirling around you, which
was viscerally a lot of fun.
And so I was working on this VR stuff
while I was at Creative Lab.
And then I moved over
to the Data Arts team,
which is another team within Google.
And this was the first thing
that I put in motion over there.
I won't dwell too much on it
since I mentioned it earlier,
but it was just a way to make
working with VR controllers easier.
But I'm happy to dwell
again on "Asteroids",
because I love that game.
So here it is translated into VR.
Or if we go back for a moment.
The original "Asteroids" is a
black and white vector game.
And that's because of the hardware.
It was built to run on a Vectrex screen.
So speaking of lasers, well I guess,
would you consider that a real laser?
- [Audience Member] No.
- No, okay.
(laughs)
I like to think of it as a laser,
but I realize that's just
because it sounds cooler,
but it's not a real, yeah.
Anyway, photon gun, electron gun?
That's more?
- Yeah.
Electron gun is different.
So that's why it looks this way.
And I wanted to translate it to VR.
And at first I was
tempted to make something
that looked like this,
but I realized conceptually
I should probably be doing
what the hardware wants,
and in a way that is truer
to the original game.
And so that's why it ends
up being these flat surfaces
with shading to indicate their depth
and where they are in space.
So with all of those little
VR pieces in my palette,
and now with the Data Arts
team, that's when I made,
and when I say I, I mean we,
the team, made "Dance Tonite".
And it's a ever changing
dance collaboration
between LCD Soundsystem and
their fans in virtual reality.
So when you load it up, you
get this little tutorial.
This ball represents the camera,
it enters the room and the room lights up,
and that means it's time to dance.
And each room represents
about eight seconds of music.
That's the amount of time it takes
for the phrasing of the
music to turn around.
So you record your dance.
And then you can actually
record multiple dances.
So it could just be you doing this,
but you could build up, I think, yeah,
20 copies of yourself if you want to.
So you can start to make more
complex movements and things,
even if you're just on your lonesome.
Here's what it looks like from the inside,
which is a little chaotic,
because this is someone actually dancing.
And...
Let's see if I can do this
with sound without feedback.
("Tonite" by LCD Soundsystem)
You can see the balls...
(feedback echoing)
♪ Everybody's singing the same song ♪
Okay, I will turn down the sound,
so I don't get that feedback.
So this way I can talk
through something like,
each one of these people is selectable.
So let's say, I'll grab one
of these folks over here.
And when I click on them,
this is their point of view camera.
So you can relive that dance experience,
which may make you sick,
since it's this added motion.
You can also, let's see where the ball is.
You can also grab the ball.
And this is a little more
of a steady cam experience.
So you are now the ball
floating through here.
And if you do this in a VR headset,
you don't just have the
straight ahead view.
You can just look around,
and it's like you're on
this slow moving carriage.
And you can see what's
happening everywhere else.
Let's see if I can jump
on the timeline here.
It goes on to this other
part of the universe,
where you're no longer
constrained to these rooms.
And you can see all
these other folks dancing
and reacting to the music.
And I think you get the
general idea for this video.
So we launched it at Google IO, again,
and we had this big party.
You can see all of this ridiculous,
we actually built rooms,
physical rooms that correspond
to those virtual rooms.
So you have this trippy experience
where you step into the physical
room, put on the headset,
you're in the virtual room.
And also people are in a ball pit,
which seems like it should not be real,
but that was physical.
Kids as adults.
You could write books about that.
And here's, yeah, just a
bit more of am overview.
I'm not making fun of this
guy by having him here.
He's actually a very well known,
well-respected VR journalist,
and I'm so excited-
- I thought that was Delorean.
- [Stewart] No.
(Stewart and audience laughing)
- [Audience Member] I'll take
it, can I do it in the room?
- So that was a lot of fun,
and a fun way to launch
the project as well.
All right.
So this is my fourth and
final project to show.
Since this is for YQI,
I should probably talk about something
quantum related maybe.
But before I do, I wanna
make something clear first.
Let's say that this circle
represents quantum physics.
This is all the knowledge
about how the universe
actually conducts itself, right?
Photons, locality,
thermodynamics, packets of light,
whatever, whatever you want to talk about.
And over here is quantum computing.
And this is pure math and logic,
and you don't need to know
so much about electrons
or superconducting to just
write computer programs.
And of course you have that intersection,
the actual quantum hardware,
quantum computers themselves.
But this is the realm
that I'm more comfortable
speaking about because
I am not a physicist,
I'm not an engineer.
And if we're being totally honest,
my personal knowledge scape
looks a little more like this.
Random puddles of knowledge.
Even this is generous, by the way.
rather than a vast ocean of knowledge
that I think many of you folks have.
But also this, 'cause we
humans are beautifully messy,
nonsensical creatures.
So with this disclaimer in mind,
I can talk about some
of my quantum projects.
So I'm the creator and maintainer
of Quantum JavaScript, or QJS for short.
And I'm the founder of Open Quantum Club.
So what is this stuff exactly?
We can go deep on QJS for a second.
It's actually a few things at once.
It's this website,
and the corresponding
source code repository.
It's this drag and drop
circuit composer interface,
in particular.
It's a quantum circuit simulator,
because this is just software, right?
It's not actual quantum hardware.
It's the entire code library
and its corresponding API.
It's some concept primers that are there
to help get folks like me up to speed
on quantum computing quickly.
You know, folks with no
real physics background
or quantum background, just casual coders
with some rusty high school math.
It turns out that's all you need
to start making some fun mistakes.
And then you can learn more as you go.
And it's the documentation
too, for the QJS API,
because what good is a library
if you don't know how to use it?
And when you put all of this together,
there's a small, but growing
community of enthusiastic folks
who have also fallen in love
with this ridiculous idea
of fusing quantum and web browsers.
Because JavaScript wasn't
chaotic enough on its own, right?
Do we have any JavaScript coders here?
Know what I'm talking about? No?
(sighs)
Really nerdy jokes. I'm so sorry.
So for this community,
I'm starting something called the OQC,
the Open Quantum Club.
And this is a project, I'm
just spinning it up right now,
through a website that will
feature profiles and interviews
with folks in the quantum community.
So the special focus here
will be on the humanity
behind the math, since that's
what I'm better at, obviously.
So who are the personalities?
What are the collective hopes and dreams
and that sort of thing?
So stay tuned for more about
that as we head towards 2023.
But let's talk about the, oh yeah?
- [Audience Member] Is it more
like an interview project?
- Yes, yeah, and I've
conducted my first interview
and forgot how difficult transcribing
a long interview could be.
So I need to finish that.
And the website is partially finished.
So it's in progress,
but not ready to launch,
but yeah, mostly interview based.
So this is the QJS website,
which is really the hub for
the whole QJS experience.
There are quantum tutorials,
the API documentation,
all the things I just mentioned.
I'm gonna play a quick demo video for you
that I made to show off
some of the features.
Okay, all right, Quantum JavaScript,
it starts off with this interactive
circuit building interface that runs
right in your web browser.
And I'll explain what these
things are in a moment,
but I'll just show you
how it operates first.
We can select everything and
throw it away and start over.
We also have an undo button
here, which is great.
And also a lock button, so
we can lock our circuit,
and can't mess it up.
Can't select things,
can't throw stuff away,
which is even more helpful
on a mobile interface,
where there is no hover
state and selection,
you're tapping.
Perhaps you're tapping to scroll,
perhaps you're tapping without meaning to,
and you definitely don't
want to mess up a circuit
that you've carefully composed.
But in this case, we can
throw down an identity gate
and maybe a Poly X gate and select them
and combine them together to
make a controlled gate here.
And what we've just created
here is a bell state.
And even if you don't
understand any of this stuff,
you can see the live probability results
being updated in real
time as we change things.
So it's really cool
that you can drag and drop stuff together,
but you can also code things,
code circuits with JavaScript.
And what's even more than that
is you can combine the two.
So if we open up our
JavaScript console here.
Let me clear it out.
It says that this circuit is
accessible in our console.
And so let's give that a shot, let's see.
We get a circuit back.
Here, let's make this a little larger.
Let's see what that circuit looks like.
We can get a diagram of it.
It's not very interesting
when we have a blank circuit.
But here, we can quickly
build that bell state again.
And you can see as I'm
editing the circuit,
we're getting real output, just like that.
And here, let me scroll up,
so we can actually see
that this ASCII diagram
looks very similar to what we
have right here, doesn't it?
And so that is pretty cool.
And what's even cooler is we
can start to do things like,
let's say we want to add
another one of those H gates.
That's a Hadamard gate,
and we'll talk about that in a second.
Let's add it to moment
three, on wire three,
which should put it right there.
Let's see if we can do
that, oh, and there it is.
So we can actually jump
back and forth between code,
and the drag and drop interface.
So it's not about dumbing
something down, not at all.
With QJS, you have access
to this quantum circuit
both through code and the
drag and drop interface,
and you can fluidly switch back and forth
to whatever has least cognitive
overhead in that moment.
Let's say I need to get
rid of everything here
in moment two.
I could certainly code that,
or I could just select
it and throw it away.
So I just want to emphasize
that designing a user interface
and offering pictures
to look at and click on
is never about dumbing something down.
It's about making tasks
easier and more efficient
for us human beings that require that.
So QJS definitely sits
on the software side.
But I happened to work
at Amazon for a while,
and Amazon just so happened to be working
on a quantum service called Amazon Braket.
You can access Braket through
a prepared Jupyter notebook,
if you know what that means,
which is similar to
other quantum services,
quantum cloud services.
So anyway, here's a little
demo video that I made
just a few months before
Braket launched publicly,
using the QJS interface to drive it.
So here I have a Jupyter notebook
with Amazon Braket loaded,
which means that I can use Python code.
Braket is a Python library.
And I can use that to
build quantum circuits
that I can then run on a
simulator in the cloud,
or I can run on quantum hardware,
because Amazon has
partnered with different
quantum hardware vendors.
And so we can do that, we can
offer that to our customers,
and that's pretty exciting.
But what's also exciting is this.
With just a few lines of HTML,
really, two lines of HTML,
I can inject QJS into
this Jupyter notebook,
it's now injected.
And now I can inject my
quantum circuit composer.
And this composer, which
should look awfully familiar,
is writing Braket code.
So this is actually Braket Python code,
which right now is set to run
on the simulator in the cloud
so that we can get quicker results.
But if you wanted to,
you could switch what
device we're running on,
and you could actually run
this on quantum hardware,
and get true quantum results.
So check this out.
Down here, you can see where
it says our QJS circuit
equals a new circuit,
and it has a placeholder identity gate.
This is Braket code, and we're
about to watch it change,
as I start to compose stuff.
Look at that, look how
it put a Hadamard gate,
and created a C-NOT gate.
And we can take that and we can run that.
What this is is a coin flip circuit.
And we're waiting for the output
to come back from the cloud.
So Hadamard puts the qubit
into a state of superposition,
and then this distributes
that superposition
to the qubit on the second register here.
And so our two possible
outcomes are 00 and 11,
and you can see, we've
gotten a result back
from the simulator.
It's run that simulation a hundred times,
which is a customizable number.
And it's come back roughly even.
54 times it came out 00,
and 46 times it came out 11.
So here's the deal.
We can drag and drop and
build circuits as we please
using the QJS drag and drop interface.
We can even edit that thing
and get real time reports
in the JavaScript console still.
And it is building Amazon Braket code,
which we can run on a simulator,
or on actual quantum hardware.
So that is pretty cool.
- So that's it for Quantum JavaScript.
- [Audience Member] I have a question.
- Yeah.
- [Audience Member] For the Amazon Braket,
is it a hardware quantum computer,
or it's also simulated?
- Both.
So they have their own,
because they have a huge
cloud infrastructure,
they have a pretty efficient simulator
that runs in the cloud.
But then they partner with Rigetti,
and, oh gosh, now the
caffeine's wearing off.
but they have a few
different hardware partners,
and so you can actually select
which system you want to use.
All right. Maybe it's
time to wrap this up.
And that's me, and the
sorts of things that I make.
I'm happy to take more questions,
or if you're curious about other work,
I'm happy to show more things.
But we can open it up a bit.
- [Florian] Why do we focus
on the web based application?
- Well, I guess there are two reasons
that I focus on web based stuff.
One is that's where I learned
to code a lot of things.
Because it's, you have
access to the source code,
even if it's not technically open source,
everything that's happening
on the front end is there,
you can just view source in the browser,
and start to pull it apart.
- [Audience Member] You can?
- Yes, yeah.
Things are a little more
locked down these days,
but there's sort of the wild
west days of the late '90s
and early 2000s where you
could take apart websites
to a much greater degree.
So that's how I learned
to do a lot of stuff.
The other reason is it's
so immediately sharable.
And I think that's pretty highly valued,
and everyone has a web
browser on their computer,
so you can also be sure
that you can run things.
And yeah, it's just a huge,
I wanna say market share,
and that's the wrong word for it.
It's a huge distribution channel.
- [Florian] Is there any limitation?
Can you do everything you
want with the browser?
Do you have sometimes, like what's the-
- Oh, there are definitely limitations.
But a lot of them are
melting away every day.
So for instance, right
now I'm playing with
a hardware accelerated
simulation algorithm for QJS.
Because you have, through the web GPU API,
you can get right onto
the graphics card hardware
and use the hardware
acceleration for that.
And in this case, instead
of making fancy graphics,
I'm just multiplying the large
matrices of quantum states.
(laughs)
- [Audience Member] How
did you get interested
in quantum computing?
- Oh, well, I should probably have
a real conceptual answer for
this, but just for a long time,
I thought quantum physics
and quantum mechanics
sounded really cool.
I was like, wow, that's neat.
And I kept trying to wrap my
head around it and I couldn't.
But I keep watching the
pop science explanations
of what quantum is, which,
once you start learning anything about it,
you're like, that's stupid.
But then I came across a video
by this guy, Andrew Heller,
I think is his name, from Microsoft.
And he gave an internal Microsoft lecture
that they published called
"Quantum Computing for
Computer Scientists",
which is him summarizing his
favorite book on the subject.
And suddenly the way he was
describing it just as coding
made a lot of sense.
And I thought, oh my god, I
bet I could just write that.
And I bet I could write
it for the browser,
and then start sharing it with folks.
And that was my first actual understanding
of how some quantum stuff works.
I would say I still don't
understand any of it.
But I could build a functioning simulator.
Any other questions?
- Yeah.
- [Audience Member] Just
a kind of follow up.
So when would someone use
the web based application
or to a desktop based application?
- That's a good question,
but I'm not sure.
There must be desktop applications,
but when I think about Qiskit,
or just the other things that I've seen
that are basically running
in Jupyter notebooks,
those things are all web based.
Even if they're presenting themselves
as a native application, under the hood,
they're basically running
little web servers and the like.
And it seems like that's okay,
because what you really want to do,
is you just want to have
an understandable interface
to take your thoughts
and put them in a way
the computer can understand.
And then you're gonna push that
to real quantum hardware anyway.
So the medium in between
doesn't really matter as much.
And even with the simulation stuff,
either you're simulating on the cloud,
so it's just sending the instructions
to many computers to come back.
Or you're trying to do
hardware acceleration
on your own local machine.
And you can do all of
that through a browser.
So you don't necessarily
need to worry about that.
- Okay.
Thank you very much for
coming, and for your questions.
Let's thank Stewart Smith one more time,
and then we'll see you, all of us,
for the public event in the fall.
Thank you very much!
(audience applauding)